I was literally canceled by FBI they
invited me to speak and then two days
literally before my event the head of
diversity calls me what to do with the
head of diversity they said your
political opinions do not align with our
values so you have to cancel your speech
did you know what's funny about it I
became American last year and in my
American citizenship the lady asked me
have you ever persecuted anybody for
their opinion if I said yes I could not
have become American
so they don't even know what it means to
be American because they never took
American citizenship tests in America
people cannot get punished for their
political opinion and this organization
like FBI all the big tech companies and
corporations punish people because of
their political opinions